♪ Another one bites the dust ♪
♪ Let's go! ♪
(door alarm buzzing)
(tense music)
(cell doors clanking)
[M] Gus March-Phillips.
(handcuffs rattling)
I have a mission I want
you to lead.
(dramatic music)
Thank you, Sergeant.
[Gus] What's the plan?
- To neutralize the German
U-boats in the North Atlantic.
(dramatic music)
(telegraph tapping)
[Churchill] We're losing the
war.
(dramatic music)
Hitler is not playing by the
rules, so neither are we.
(dramatic music)
- We both know that I'm not very
popular
with the administration.
- The reason they find you
unattractive
is the very reason I find you
attractive.
("Another One Bites the Dust")
- If I'm to do this,
I'll need my own team.
(guns cocking)
You won't like them.
♪ Let's go ♪
[Gus] They're all, uh...
[Both] No!
- mad.
- They'll need to be.
♪ Steve walks warily down the
street ♪
♪ With the brim pulled way down
low ♪
[Gus] This is an unsanctioned,
unauthorized mission.
♪ Machine guns ready to go ♪
♪ Are you ready ♪
♪ Are you ready for this ♪
- If we fail,
England will be condemned
to a lifetime under the German
boot.
♪ The bullets rip ♪
♪ To the sound of the beat, yeah
♪
[Joker] And so I said, "That is
not a dog.
That is my wife!"
(group laughing)
(Gus laughing)
- It's very good.
♪ Let's go ♪
(guns firing)
(dramatic music)
♪ Another one bites the dust ♪
♪ And another one's gone,
and another one's gone ♪
♪ Another one bites the dust ♪
♪ Gonna get you, too ♪
♪ Another one ♪
[Admiral Pound] You and your
operation are reckless.
(explosion booms)
♪ Another one bites the dust ♪
♪ Hey, hey ♪
♪ Another one bites ♪
- Abort this mission now!
♪ Another one bites the dust ♪
(explosion booms)
- Hello? Can't hear you.
Please do-
(static crackling)
(grenade pin pings)
(German officer gasps)
♪ Another one, another one ♪
(explosion booms)
♪ Another one bites the dust ♪
(dramatic music)